오늘 비사남이 간다는 우리나라의
금융의 중심지 여의도에
왔습니다. 네. 저는 색각력에 왔는데
저기 맞은편에 저렇게 펜스 쳐져 있는
곳이 있습니다. 저기 원래 이제
여러분들이 잘 아시던 어 주유소
부지였는데 그걸 이제 멸시를 했어요.
그래서 요게 아마 신축하데 있어서
지금 트럼프 월드 타워랑 좀 붙어
있거든요. 그래서 여기 사시는
주민분들이랑 좀 뭐 여러 가지 이슈
때문에 공사가 좀 많이 딜레이된
상태인 거 같습니다. 그래서 그때
당시에 매각됐을 때 제가 알고
있기로는 한 평당 2억 정도 매각이
됐었고 두 필지가 있는데 하나는
440억, 하나는 뭐 292억 뭐이
정도의 매각이 돼서 어 여기 대로변에
위치가 굉장히 좋은데 그리고 여기가
또 이제 상업지거든요. 건물을 굉장히
좀 높게 올릴 수 있습니다. 땅의
가치는 되게 좋기는 한데 아마 이제
주변에 있는이 주거지에 사시는 분들의
뭔가 민원이나 뭐 이런 것 때문에
공사가 좀 계속 늦혀지고 있지 않나?
어 네. 그렇게 예상을 하고
있습니다. 그리고 이쪽 여의도 건물
자체가 굉장히 좀 오래된 건물들이
많아요. 상업용 건물들도 보면은 뭐
70년대, 60년대 지금 건물들이
많아서 여러분들 아마 이제 주차하려고
막 건물 들어가 보시면 진짜 깜짝
놀랄 정도로 되게 노후화 되고 진짜
주차장도 엄청 좁은 그런 건물들이
아직까지도 많이 있습니다. 지금
여의도가
용적률 상향 이슈가 좀 있긴
하거든요. 그래서 이렇게 업무나 상업
지구 같은 경우에는 기준 요건만 좀
맞으면까지 올려주는 어 그런 지구
단위 계획을 만들었습니다. 건물이
지금 파크원이 제일 높아요.
여의도에서 한 33m로 69층입니다.
근데 그거보다 더 높은 건물들도 많이
나올 것 같아요. 근데 문제는 뭐냐면
너무 오래된 건물들이 많습니다. 그
건물들이 임차인도 되게 잘게 잘게
쪼개져 있고 제가 아마 이전 영상에도
좀 보셨겠지만 아무리 토지 활용도가
높다 하더라도 그렇게 이해 관계인이
많으면 개발하는데 시간이 많이
소요됩니다. 워낙 낡은 이런 상업용
건물이 많기 때문에 그거를 좀 어떻게
풀지를 좀 고민을 많이 해 봐야 될
거 같아요. 그리고 지금 여기에
오래된 아파트들이 되게 많거든요.
그래서 여기 앞에 보시면 그 미성
아파트도 보이는데 대부분 다
70년도에 지은 아파트들이 많습니다.
물론 재건축 얘기가 진짜 오래 전부터
있긴 했는데 그것도 어찌 됐든 이해
관계인이 워낙 많다 보니까 시간이 좀
많이 소요될 것으로 외상이 돼요.
주어지 같은 경우에는 기준 요건만 좀
맞으면 최대 용적률을 800%까지
올려 준다라고 합니다. 근데 지금
제가 알고 있기로는 서울시 내에서
용적률 800% 받은 이런 주거
지역이 없거든요. 그래서 만약에 진짜
그게 받는다라고 하면 정말 초고층
빌딩의 그런 주거 시설들이 좀 많이
생길 것으로 예상이 돼요. 저 건물도
보면은 진짜 엄청 잘게 잘게 많이
쪼개져 있어요. 임차인도 너무 많고
실질적으로 좀 개발하기가 되게
어렵습니다. 근데 저는 진짜
안타까운게 지금 우리나라 GDP가
4만 불을 거의 향해 가고 있는데
아직까지 이렇게 좀 그때 당시에
1900 막 70년도 80년도에 진짜
지었던 GDP 막 막 10분 정도
수준이었던 그 시절에 아파트가
있으니까 좀 안타깝긴 합니다. 물론
뭐 여러 이해 관계인이 있긴 하겠지만
좀 개발이 좀 잘 됐으면 좋겠습니다.
그래서 저는 지금 더연대 서울 앞에
와 있습니다. 어 도현대 서울이
서울시 백화점 중에서는 가장 큰
면적이고 그리고 매출이 지금 우리나라
기준으로 한 9위 정도 한다라고
합니다. 그리고 최단기간에 연매출
1조를 넘은 어 그런 백화점인데 지금
여기는 사실 국내 사람뿐만 아니라
외국인 관광객들한테도 인기가 굉장히
많아요. 그래서 외국인들도 지금
한국에 여행을 왔을 때 여기
더연대소를 많이 찾는다라고 합니다.
그리고 최근에는 이런 팝업 스토어도
굉장히 좀 많이 열리고 있어 가지고
젊은 사람들 그니까 MG의 성지라고
좀 보시면 될 거 같아요. 그리고
여기 맞은 편에는 IFC 몰이
있거든요. 그래서 거기도 이제 상업
시설이 있는데 거기도 작년에
불황인데도 불구하고 최고 매출을
찍었다라고 합니다. 그래서 지금
여의도의이 상업 시설이 잘 된다라는게
뭐 직장인뿐만 아니라 외부에서도
이쪽을 좀 많이 찾아온다라고 보시면
될 거 같아요. 주말에도 사람이
굉장히 많습니다. 여의도 내에서 상업
시설을 이용할 수 있는 서울에서 가장
좋은 한국에서 제일 탑의
백화점이라든지 이런 IFC 몰 같은게
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
여기가 나중에 이제 뭐 주거 시설이
개발되고 하면은 아마 뭐 이쪽으로
오는 사람들이 더 많아지지 않을까
그렇게 좀 예상하고
있습니다. 네. 저는 여의도 공원에
왔는데 여의도를 좀 총평해 보자면
여의도가 그 서울시 기본 계획에 좀
잡혀 있어요. 그래서 2030년뿐만
아니라 2040년 계획에도 여의도를
개발해야겠다라는 그런 기본 계획에
나와 있습니다. 그래서 지금 여의도
쪽이랑 그다음에 용산, 강남 이렇게
세 군데를 합쳐서 지금 개발 계획이
좀 있거든요. 그래서 앞으로 서울시도
여의도를 개발하려고 많이 노력을 할
거예요. 그래서 최근에 지금 용적률도
최대로 좀 높여진 부분도 있고 그런
것 때문에 여의도의 빌딩들이 정말 좀
많이 높아질 것 같고 좀 상징성 있는
그런 건물들도 많이 나올 것
같습니다. 그리고 주거 시설도 지금
대부분 다 노후화된 어 그런 주거
시설이 많은데 그 주거 시설도 진짜
최대 용적률 한 800%까지 그렇게
받을 수 있는 그런 초고층 주거
시설도 많이 나올 것 같습니다.
파워펠팰렛스 같은 그런 주거 시설이
좀 많이 나올 거 같아요. 그래서
지금 주거 시설뿐만 아니라 뭐 지금
업무 시설 그다음에 지금 보이시는
여기 공원 공원이 진짜 메리트거든요.
지금 뉴욕에서 저희도 받겠지만 그
센트럴 파크도 있잖아요. 이런
사람들이 좀 오게 하려면 공원이
있어야지 옵니다. 성수동 같은
경우에도 서울숲을 가듯이 그래서 지금
여의도 공원뿐만 아니라 저는 또
여의도의 메리트가 뭐냐면
한강이거든요. 한강 공원이 바로 앞에
있기 때문에 전체적으로 봤을 때 여기
여의도에 사실 땅이 그렇게 크진
않지만 어 모든게 다 갖춰져 있다라고
저는 생각을 합니다. 그리고 지금
그것뿐만 아니라 지금 더연대라든지이
IFC 몰 같은 경우에도 상업 시설이
워낙 잘 돼 있기 때문에 저는 투자
가치는 더 높아질 것으로 좀 예상이
돼요. 근데 제가 앞서 설명드렸던
것처럼 노후화된 건물이 너무 많은데
일단 이해 관계인이 너무 많아요. 어
임차인도 너무 많고 되게 잘게 잘게
쪼개져 있습니다. 그래서 그거를 사실
실질적으로 좀 개발하기에는 쉽진 않을
것 같아요. 그래서 시간도 좀 오래
걸릴 것 같고. 어, 앞으로 좀
장기적으로 봤을 때는 서울시에서도
밀어주고 지금 뭐 여러 가지 개발
호재가 있어서 여의도의 투자 가치를
되게 높게 평가합니다. 역도
추가적으로 들어오거든요. 지금
5호선이랑 9호선 들어와 있는데 지금
GTX도 들어오고 신 안산선도
들어오거든요. 앞으로 더 여의도의
교통 환경이라든지 이런게 좀 더
좋아질 것 같습니다. 매각 사례를 좀
설명드리면 여의도 쪽에 이제 대로변에
평균적으로 매각된게 한 3천만 원대
매각이 된 거 같아요. 면적당
테란로가 지금 거의 한 4천만 원,
5천만 원 수준인데 그거보다는 확실히
좀 저렴한 펀이긴 합니다. 이면의
건물들은 옆면적당 한 평당 한 2천만
원인 거 같아요. 확실히 지금
아직까지는 가격이 그렇게 높진 않기
때문에 저는 투자 가치가 충분히
있다라고 좀 생각을 합니다. 네.
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요.
여러분들 빌딩은 역시 빌사나
[음악]